this video is sponsored by the book
summary app blinkist
also for those interested you'll find
more insights on philosophical topics
like the ones covered in this video and
my new book of collected works the art
of living a meaningless existence which
you can also find through its respective
link in the description
when it happens happiness can often feel
more troubling than comforting it feels
like something is not quite right it
almost intimates an end a sort of death
for many of us happiness does not feel
like home what we seem to prefer rather
is the strange paradoxical comfort of
misery's discomfort the soothing
darkness of melancholy the striving
agitation of discontent
how is it or why is it that we can be so
intelligent so aware so equipped perhaps
successful and well-off in the
traditional societal sense and yet we
could still feel so unhappy we appear to
be unable to obtain what we want and set
out to accomplish
perfect happiness and contentment and
peace
perhaps this is because in part we
actually do not want these things
perhaps we are far less aware of what we
really want and how our mind really
works
if right now you could push a button and
feel nothing but bliss for the rest of
your life or push a button and never
feel misery or discontent ever again
would you do it
if not
why
what does this suggest about what you
really want and value in life
if experiencing the so-called ideal all
the time is not ideal and never
experiencing the so-called undesirable
is undesirable are these things really
as they seem in aldous huxley's novel
brave new world john says
but i don't want comfort i want god i
want poetry i want real danger i want
freedom i want goodness i want sin
arguably like a tyrannical government
concealing the truth from its people to
maintain order and function of its state
we are told by our conscious mind that
we desire happiness and that happiness
is the goal while simultaneously our
conscious mind conceals from us that our
real desire is a sort of unhappiness a
continual state of discontent and all
the states and views that grow out of
its muddy but fertile soil
the pursuit of happiness seems to be a
mirage created by the opposing
temperatures of our conscious and
unconscious minds the heat of our
conscious desires and hopes met with the
cold indifference of our unconscious
mind's continually unsatisfiable nature
this might sound bleak and absurd and
perhaps it is on some level but perhaps
it isn't totally
20th century philosopher ludwig
wickenstein described himself as being
miserable his entire life he was
afflicted by depression anxiety anger
self-loathing loneliness and an
unyielding impossible desire for
perfection and philosophical truth of
which he of course never found he
frequently discussed with others and
wrote in his diary about these
afflictions throughout his life and yet
on his deathbed reportedly his last
words were
tell them i've had a wonderful life
this final testament and endorsement of
his life raises the question how could
someone who lived their life in misery
also claim they lived a wonderful life
what does this mean about what a
wonderful life is or could be and how
happiness and misery play a role in its
development the dichotomy of
wittgenstein's life and his final
testimony at the end of it reveals its
own remarkable philosophical insight the
strange divergence between day-to-day
happiness and the quality of the net
outcome of one's life
of course there are different degrees of
misery some that are not in the category
of functional melancholy discontent and
the sort of existential suffering of all
conscious being is likely different than
depression or a lifetime of overdrawn
misery and it isn't always obvious which
is which and none of this is to say that
there isn't anything good or enjoyable
throughout life that isn't worth being
happy about and nor is it to say that
there are not things and methods that
generally make life better things like
diet exercise good sleep financial
stability and at least a few close
friends and loved ones can make a
substantial difference and ought to be
optimized as best as one can but in the
context of a purposeful life it is to
say that perhaps a good life is not one
without misery but rather it is one that
is often seeping with it
consider the creation of a great work of
art or the creative process more broadly
the creative process can often be seen
as some enchanted process of a divine
burst of inspiration and talent what it
more typically is however is a process
of continual dissatisfaction
a great piece of creative work does not
merely emerge out of a burst of
inspiration and effort but rather a
collection of these bursts forced or
natural in which most amount to nothing
something the creator finds
unsatisfactory the creative person
however continues on through the process
until they evolve the work into
something satisfactory at least enough
one might be immersed and perhaps in
some sort of flow state during certain
stages of this process which is arguably
some amount pleasant but broadly the
creative process is beset with
uncertainty self-doubt misery stress and
discontent moreover the degree of how
great a creative work is often largely
depends on how unhappy the creator was
with their work throughout the process
all the way up until the final form of
it after countless brush strokes key
pushes pages written answers attempted
and so on all of which were deemed as
not good enough
by the end relief and perhaps pride in
some form of meaningfulness is likely to
be experienced exhaustion fueled
willingness to move on but not happiness
not in the traditional sense at least
happiness never really enters the stage
at least not for long it appears on the
program booklet but its character never
really makes much of an appearance
and yet the show is still incredible
somehow still desirable and worthwhile
if persevered through the creative
person almost always returns to do it
again and again and again
what is life if not merely the greatest
art piece we will all create
the philosopher friedrich nietzsche
argued that the process of continually
defining striving and achieving new
ideals and goals in life is the means
through which an individual can achieve
a meaningful and worthwhile life he
referred to this concept as
self-overcoming in order to achieve and
sustain this process he suggested that
one must continually set up an
ever-evolving ideal version of
themselves with which they can aim and
strive toward he would term this ideal
self the ubermensch by continually
creating a new image of the ubermensch
and then recurrently going through a
process of self-destruction and
self-creation toward it the individual
for nietzsche justifies life's suffering
and develops personal meaning and
greatness through it
what is needed throughout this process
though is a continual sense of
dissatisfaction and misery a sense that
the work of art of one's own life is not
yet good enough
in this paradigm the basis of meaning is
self-creation and self-improvement the
basis of creation and improvement
however is desire and the basis of
desire is discontentment
and here is where the sort of reflexive
interdependent relationship between
desire and misery emerges
if we agree with this paradigm in a sort
of strange way we desire desires
continuation and we need discontentment
and the misery that stems from it for
this to occur
the end of desire is the end of sorrow
wrote the buddha and so desire and
sorrow are in this way inexorably
interlocked two sides of the same coin
thus in a strange way if it is true that
we want to persist our desire we desire
this sort of existential sorrow
in an even stranger way by not having
our desires satisfied we satisfy our
ultimate desire the desire for the
continuation of desire
if rather happiness is the highest
possible goal then this form of meaning
and agency is undermined
in the gay science nietzsche wrote when
i think of the desire to do something
how it continually tickles and
stimulates millions of young europeans
who cannot endure themselves in all
their unwe i conceive that there must be
a desire in them to suffer something in
order to derive from the suffering a
worthy motive for acting for doing
something distress is necessary this
young world desires that there should
arrive from the outside not happiness
but misfortune and their imagination is
already busy beforehand to form a
monster out of it so that they may
afterwards be able to fight with a
monster
arguably whether we are familiar with
nietzsche's ideas or not a vast majority
of us in the modern western world live
our lives with at least some sense of
and calibration with this paradigm
and so if and when happiness does occur
in our lives or we obtain the conditions
that would allow for it to many of us do
not accept it fully instead we might
sabotage it we might reject it we might
look for what's still wrong or contrive
something being wrong if there isn't
anything
philosopher arthur schopenhauer wrote
the safest way of not being very
miserable is not to expect to be very
happy
perhaps a more apt version is
the safest way of not being very
miserable is to realize your taste for
misery
of course the idea of liking justifying
or pursuing sorrow and discontent isn't
without reasonable critiques if every
time your life gets better it's still
not good enough and essentially feels
the same no matter how much better life
gets if it feels the same how much
better is it really
and what is the point of life if not to
be at least some amount happy as
reasonably often as possible
perhaps it is a matter of being as happy
as possible while living the most
meaningfully interesting life possible
reaping and persisting through suffering
and enjoying happiness presently and
fully when it comes and when we can
like most things it is perhaps an
impossible constant balancing act unique
to the valuation and strength of each
individual
ultimately though it seems that if we
want engagement wonder meaning greatness
and a continual sense of forward motion
to some degree we should embrace our
desire for discontent until finally at
the end of our life when we have done
everything we could to produce the
greatest piece of art that is our being
and we are exhausted and ready to move
on we are able to say
tell them i've had a wonderful life
this video was sponsored by blinkist
on average john reads about one book per
month emmett spends around the same
amount of time each month learning from
books as john
over a single year john read about 10
books
emmett however learned from 327 books
emmett was also able to explore tons of
different books and authors not only in
his favorite subjects but also on other
subjects that he was able to discover
that he was interested in
how is this possible though if they both
spent the same amount of time
emmett used the book summary app
blinkist which condenses over 5000
nonfiction books into around 15 minute
summaries using blinkist emmett was able
to listen to and read summaries during
his downtime his commute while he worked
out and so on even while he was offline
easily able to refresh himself on key
parts of his favorite books and discover
new ones saving plenty of time to still
read complete books throughout the year
when he found the ones he was most
interested in
in a single day he learned from several
books including atomic habits by james
clear and essentialism by greg mcewen
and learned practical ways to consider
and cut out the metaphorical fat from
his life focus his priorities on what
matters to him and better understand
habit building toward what does
additionally he also had time to
discover and explore his new interest in
books on personal finance all the while
john on the same day remained on the one
book he had been reading mostly on the
same subjects he always read
if you're interested in going the same
route as emmett blinkist is available
for you as well and if you use the link
in the description you'll receive one
free week of unlimited access as well as
25 off a premium membership the free
seven day trial can be canceled at any
time within the trial period
and of course as always thank you so
much for watching in general and see you
next video
[Music]
you